7 heures ce vendredi matin sous l'oeil
des crs une cinquantaine de surveillants
pénitentiaires de la maison d'arrêt de
bois d'arcy est en place depuis une
heure pour bloquer l'accès au site
plusieurs syndicats ont rejeté hier les
dernières propositions du ministère de
la justice
ils reconnaissent une avancée sur les
mesures pour la sécurité des agents mais
attendent une meilleure revalorisation
de leur statut est revenu le
gouvernement a pourtant prévu une
enveloppe de 30 millions d'euros pour
augmenter les indemnités salariales
nous on lâchera rien on restera jusqu'à
ce qu'on peut rester voilà tout en
gardant kmt deuil avec l'intérieur de
l'habitation ça s'en crée des tensions
sur la détention de m'en restera jusqu'à
ce qu'il faut rester à bois d'arcy comme
dans une soixantaine de prisons
françaises encore aujourd'hui les
surveillants sont mobilisés depuis 12
jours et des débrayages qui impacte
directement la vie de la détention
ces impacts totalement puisque à l'heure
actuelle vous avez le service de nuit
qui est mobilisée encore un cas de deux
d'événements particuliers sur invitation
mais il ya aucune aucune vie dans la
détention c'est dire que tous les
détenus sont à l'intérieur et nous on
n'ouvre aucune porte
il se passe plus rien à la détention la
détention et au paiement après l'arrivée
des pompiers pour éteindre la barricade
enflammée les crs se prépare et charges
pour déloger les manifestants regroupés
derrière le portail d'entrée
les forces de police parvienne
finalement à pénétrer dans l'enceinte de
la maison d'arrêt vers 9h30 la
manifestation s'est ensuite poursuivie à
l'intérieur du site
une crise dans les prisons françaises
qui semble s'enliser ce vendredi la
ministre de la justice nicole belloubet
a appelé les surveillants à prendre leur
responsabilité pour la sécurité de la
société